hello freak [ __ ] and I also met a lot
of rich people in my time in our
miserable day sir certainly can be
changing that yeah very isolated and I
know I could kind on my hands they might
have really rich people I know who lives
happy life who seem like they know what
to do with their money and they think
people definitely right there you know
they have all their happy marriages
happy kids balanced kids you know the
know when to have fun in order to work
hard you know blah blah blah blah but
they're the exception to the rule yeah
super rare and well the pursuit is such
a strange pursuit because you know in
often times when you're pursuing wealth
you're pursuing wealth at all costs and
that is that the ultimate goal is the
score that you put on the board I mean
that's the Gordon Gekko philosophy greed
is good right our greed will protect me
I mean I understand it why people feel
and they're not always wrong either
where money can protect you from a lot
of our presidencies that's our president
I mean our president is essentially the
greatest good guy I mean he mean that is
who he is I mean that's what he's done I
mean he has all know he made whelmed at
all cost but he was also born into
wealth a little bit yeah and I really
was a little bit I think it was a
staunch element of money he inherited
well he was given two million dollars to
start his business first business yes
and he talks about a small loan small
loan no small loan of two million
dollars yeah yeah yes yeah I mean it's
just
he certainly has inherited quite a bit
of it we no doubt no doubt about it but
my point is that his philosophy and like
what he's always pursued is extravagance
like the big gold letters on the side of
the skyscrapers that's the thing yeah
and it's it's a sting it's in a lot of
ways it's a dangerous ideology for a
country to aspire to because everybody
can't yeah impossible can't attain that
so what used then saying to people who
have that who will never have that
that's kind of what leaves me in great
dismay I understand the pursuit of money
and economic well-being by oh I feel
like what do we then say to the people
that don't have that and never will have
that right there must be something else
other than the worst thing of money yeah
it's a hollow pursuit it's an it's a
pursuit that's like it's not
and closely enough for its hollow nest
that's a word I was having a
conversation once with this friend of
mine who is a pretty radical black guy
so pretty radical african-american and
just very proud of african-american
heritage and he he went on this thing
about how black people used to be Kings
he's like we were Kings
to understand that I go stop I go you
can't everybody can't be a king because
if you have a bunch of Kings like to be
a Kings to be a dictator okay that means
you're dominating people who aren't
Kings that's not a proud thing like you
gotta stop saying that like you say it's
the wrong thought process but it's the
thought process is his in his eye he had
examined it like his in his ideas like
at one point time we were Africans we
were kings we were that we were on top
and then you know slavery and all this
other stuff so it is like his thought
process was kind of convoluted and by
saying we were kings like you don't want
to be a [ __ ] King man like nobody
should be a [ __ ] king should be zero
Kings you definitely don't want to see
we were Kings like we can be Kings again
like don't be a king yeah I don't want
to be king I don't be a queen that's a
big thing with fighters like some
fighters call themselves King this or
King that they like the part of their
name you know it's a weird it's only
African American guys I don't know any
white guys call himself King oh come on
we don't owe finally white fighter Oh
d'argo need know about that world yeah
like Bobby King Green King Bobby Green
King mo I know I know like five or six
times when you feel that you're you're a
disadvantage in us is society you know
words are powerful and they send the
words we tell ourselves are really
powerful and perhaps you can manifest a
power that you need sometimes we all
need it sometimes I know I need it
myself you know we're you know you think
to yourself okay you need to remember
what you have done what you've
accomplished who you are who your mother
is
you know I think that there's a lot to
be said I guess sure
for the casual use of certain words but
you're right I mean as as we continue to
use these words we have to examine our
meaning yeah I think I definitely think
that's the case I think that it the
well that all costs is a foolish pursuit
that people look at when they don't have
the wealth I mean that's when it becomes
an attractive thing is the idea that you
know you just got to get that paper well
when you've got the wealth I think the
greediest people are the people who are
I've got [ __ ] loads of money that we see
a lot of these these people with money
wanting to cut that have their taxes cut
rather than inject some taxes into the
community I mean I'd much rather live in
a more pleasant community than sit in my
golden tower by myself with like riots
going on you know I mean I feel like if
you make everybody happy err yes I still
be rich you can have a nicer garden to
work int that's a very good attitude
very good attitude I think it's a weird
game that people play or it becomes just
about getting those points up on the
board and they become the numbers become
meaningless like you don't sing you
don't think I have 30 million dollars I
can't spend this this is if I live a
normal life I'm good they don't think
that they think I need 50 million I need
an island well then how much is enough
babe yeah you know how much is enough
and of course the more you accumulate
the more your expenses are and the more
you want
so just goes on and on and on and on
there's an amazing Radiolab podcast it's
out now about Bernie Madoff oh there's a
show coming yes he's Robert De Niro
playing brighter she's still hot as [ __ ]
she's so hot gotta be 89 years old now
ha ha ha yes still so beautiful so hot
it's crazy
underutilized actress I'm looking for
I'm sorry I upset I don't no worries
but it's just that we interview him and
you get to hear him talk and the
reporter called him in jail and it's
really fascinating way they had to
communicate because they're only allowed
to communicate for 15 minutes and then
they have to the phone is disconnected
and then they have to wait 15 minutes
for they can reconnect so he's doing
this yeah that's just the rules of the
prison so they're doing the Amy he's in
there forever
he's never getting out of that [ __ ]
cage yeah but it's fascinating when you
hear him he has zero empathy I mean none
it's weird it's weird hearing him talk
about these people that he ripped off
and finding these like all they
find these people that you know they
they had money it's like news you know
but they're not it's no big deal like
and you listening to the way this guy
sort of rationalized but he is
essentially the poster boy for that
greed at all cost because he was just it
was running a Ponzi scheme he's stealing
money from people
[Applause]
[Music]